>> I TOLD YOU THIS WOULD BE
THREE WEEKS.
I’M NOW COMMITTING TO TWO WEEKS.
WE’RE DELIVERING ON OUR
COMMITMENTS.
THE IRS WITHIN TWO WEEKS, WHICH
I OVERSEE.
>> Sandra: SECRETARY MNUCHIN
PROMISING HELP IS COMING FOR
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
IT COMES AS A NEW MONTHLY JOBS
REPORT IS OUT AS OF THIS
MORNING.
IT SHOWS THAT U.S. EMPLOYERS
CUT 701,000 JOBS IN THE MONTH
OF MARCH AS THIS PANDEMIC
CONTINUES AND VIRTUALLY LEADS
TO A SHUTDOWN OF THE U.S.
ECONOMY AND THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE THAT HEADLINE NUMBER.
IT JUMPED TO 4.4% BUT MAY NOT
PAINT THE ENTIRE PICTURE AS TO
JUST HOW MANY MAY BE SUFFERING
FROM THIS RIGHT NOW.
LET’S SEE HOW THE MARKETS ARE
REACTING TO ALL OF IT THIS
MORNING.
THE DOW INITIALLY SELLING OFF
DOWN 200 POINTS HERE AT THE
10:30 A.M. EASTERN TIME.
NOW TO BRING IN ON ALL OF THIS
IS WHITE HOUSE ECONOMIC ADVISOR
LARRY KUDLOW.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THIS MORNING.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
>> Sandra: I WANT TO GET FIRST
YOUR REACTION TO THOSE NUMBERS.
THIS DOESN’T INCLUDE TWO MONTHS
OF MARCH WHERE WE SAW A VIRTUAL
SHUTDOWN OF THE U.S. ECONOMY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE ACTUAL
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS IN THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL LOOK, I’M NOT GOING TO
GUESSTIMATE THAT.
I WILL SIMPLY SAY THESE ARE
ROUGH NUMBERS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING.
AND I WILL SAY THE WEEKS AHEAD
I THINK THE NUMBERS ARE ALSO
GOING TO BE VERY POOR.
IT IS AN INTERRUPTION OF WHAT
WAS A VERY PROSPEROUS ECONOMY,
AN INTERRUPTION FROM THE VIRUS
AND THE NECESSARY MITIGATION
EFFORTS TO DEAL WITH THE VIRUS.
ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
DEVOTED ENORMOUS RESOURCES AND
WORK WITH OUR RESCUE PACKAGE TO
ADD CASH AND LIQUIDITY, TRY TO
KEEP INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
AFLOAT AND KEEP SMALL
BUSINESSES AFLOAT.
WE’VE WORKED WITH THE FEDERAL
SERVE AS NEVER BEFORE.
THE TOTAL PACKAGE IS A THIRD OF
GDP, A THIRD OF OUR ECONOMY
THAT’S HOW WIDESPREAD AND
MASSIVE.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT IS TOUGH,
REACH OUT TO THOSE FOLKS, IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT.
WE’RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO DEAL WITH IT AND MAKE IT
PERHAPS A LITTLE EASIER.
WE ARE TRYING TO SAVE JOBS,
SAVE PAYROLLS AND BUSINESSES SO
THAT WHEN THIS VIRUS RUNS ITS
COURSE, AS IT WILL, IT IS NOT
PERMANENT.
THIS IS A TEMPORARY ISSUE.
AS IT RUNS ITS COURSE THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY WILL BE READY
TO SNAP BACK.
I BELIEVE IT WILL HAPPEN WELL
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR.
>> Sandra: THAT’S A STRONG
FORECAST.
BANK OF AMERICA PUT OUT A DIRE
NOTE SAYING THAT WE’RE ENTERING
THE DEEPEST RECESSION ON RECORD.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THREE
STRAIGHT QUARTERS OF
CONTRACTION.
7% CONTRACTION, 30% IN THE
THIRD QUARTER.
ANOTHER PERCENT IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER.
YOU LOOK AT ECONOMIC MODELS ALL
THE TIME.
PART OF IT IS LOOKING AT THE
SMALL BUSINESSES, THE ENGINE OF
THIS ECONOMY.
THERE IS CONCERN THAT SOME OF
THE BANKS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
GIVING THESE LOANS DON’T REALLY
KNOW THE GUIDELINES AND THERE
IS SOME CONFUSION AS TO HOW
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO ADMINISTER
THOSE.
THAT’S SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN THIS
WEEK.
WHAT’S THE UPDATE ON THE
INFORMATION GETTING TO THOSE
BANKS?
>> I THINK THE INFORMATION HAS
GOTTEN THERE.
TREASURY SECRETARY MNUCHIN HAS
DONE A TERRIFIC JOB OVERSEEING
A MASSIVE PROGRAM.
WE NEVER TRIED ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
350 BILLION.
IF YOU KEEP YOUR PAYROLL INTACT.
1% LOAN.
THE BANK PARTICIPATION, LOOK,
ALL DURING THE WEEK SECRETARY
MNUCHIN AND OTHERS OF US HAVE
BEEN TALKING TO THE BANKERS AND
THEY CAME IN WITH CONSTRUCTIVE
SUGGESTIONS AND THOSE HAVE BEEN
INCORPORATED INTO THE PLAN.
THE PLAN BEGINS TODAY, I GUESS.
AND THE APPLICATIONS SHOULD
FLOW.
YOU HAVE A WIDE -- VIRTUALLY
THE WHOLE BANKING COMMUNITY
WILL TAKE PART IN THIS.
FEDERAL RESERVE, BANKS, FDIC
INSURED BANKS, CREDIT UNIONS,
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO BE
INVOLVED.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE HARD.
IF ANYBODY NEEDS TO FIND OUT
HIT THE SBA WEBSITE AND YOU
WILL GET THE BANK CLOSEST TO
YOU.
I THINK THIS THING IS READY TO
GO AND LOOK, THESE ARE
GOVERNMENT GUARANTEED LOANS.
THE BANKS KNOW THAT.
WE’VE GIVEN THE BANKS A DECENT
RATE OF RETURN ON THE LOANS,
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT PART IS
THAT SMALL BUSINESS FOLKS
APPLYING FOR THE LOANS ARE
GOING THE TRY TO KEEP THIS
ECONOMY GOING OR AT LEAST KEEP
THEIR EMPLOYEES ATTACHED TO THE
BUSINESS.
THAT’S SO IMPORTANT.
THAT’S THE KEY POINT IN ALL
THIS.
I THINK THE RESOURCES AND THE
EXECUTION ARE GOING TO BE VERY
GOOD.
LET’S WAIT AND SEE.
I THINK THE BANKERS ARE READY
TO PLAY AND I KNOW THAT FOLKS
NEED THE HELP.
>> Sandra: IT WOULD BE A HUGE
HELP BECAUSE THIS WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO RETAIN THOSE WORKERS,
PAY THOSE WAGES, PAY THE RENT
AND UTILITIES AND EVENTUALLY BE
A GRANT THE WAY IT IS
STRUCTURED.
SECRETARY MNUCHIN TWEETED OUT,
I GOT FIRST REPORT ON PPP LOAN.
SYSTEM UP AND RUNNING.
COMMUNITY BANKS HAVE PROCESSED
OVER 700 LOANS.
PROCESS FOR 2.5 MILLION.
WHAT ABOUT THE BIGGER BANKS,
LARRY?
J.P. MORGAN TOLD ITS SMALL
BUSINESS CUSTOMERS IT SHOULD
NOT EXPECT THAT THEY WILL START
ACCEPTING THOSE OM INDICATION
APPLICATIONS THIS WEEK.
WHEN DOES THE GUIDANCE GET TO
THEM?
J.P. MORGAN IS ONE OF THE BIG
GUYS?
>> I CAN’T SPEAK FOR J.P.
MORGAN.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THEY’VE BEEN
INFORMED.
I WILL SAY THAT MR. MOYNIHAN,
THE CEO OF THE BANK OF AMERICA
WHO IS AN EXTREMELY PROMINENT
BANKER, HE HAS BEEN VISITING
WITH STEVE MNUCHIN AND WORKED
HAND IN GLOVE ON THIS AND HE IS
READY TO GO.
I CAN’T ACCOUNT FOR THE BIG
BANKS.
LOOK, THE KEY POINT HERE IS I
THINK THE ARRANGEMENTS AND THE
ADJUSTMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE.
MR. MNUCHIN HAS SAID WE’RE OPEN
FOR BUSINESS ON THIS.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE HARD.
EVENTUALLY THE BANKS WILL PLAY.
LOOK, SANDRA, ONE ADDITIONAL
POINT.
IT IS A SPENDING PROGRAM AND
PAYROLL PROTECTION BUT DON’T
FORGET WE’RE PUTTING OUT $600
BILLION OF ASSISTANCE.
AN TOP OF THIS PURCHASING $600
BILLION FOR INDIVIDUALS, FOR
FAMILIES, FOR SICK LEAVE, FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT.
175 MILLION AMERICANS.
175 MILLION AMERICANS WILL
RECEIVE CHECKS AND OTHER FORMS
OF ASSISTANCE.
IT IS THE MOST REMARKABLE THING
WE’VE EVER DONE AND WORKING
HAND IN GLOVE COOPERATING WITH
THE FEDERAL RESERVE ON THEIR
LENDING PROGRAMS SO FISCAL AND
MONETARY POLICY IS WORKING
TOGETHER.
THIS -- NOTHING LIKE THIS WAS
EVER TRIED BEFORE.
KEEP PEOPLE GOING.
>> Sandra: SO MANY AREN’T GOING
RIGHT NOW.
SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LAID
OFF.
I UNDERSTAND IT IS A MASSIVE
COORDINATED EFFORT.
WE GET THAT.
BUT THEN YOU LOOK AT THE
MEDICAL SIDE OF THINGS AND
WE’RE NOT OUT OF THE DARKEST
HOUR OF THIS YET BUT AS THE
CHIEF ECONOMIC ADVISOR TO THE
PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO START LOOKING AT HOW YOU
REOPEN THE ECONOMY ONCE THINGS
DO GET BETTER.
SO FINAL THOUGHT ON THAT NOTE.
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE TO GET
THIS ECONOMY RUNNING AGAIN?
>> LOOK, THE FIRST THING IS
REALLY TO IMPLEMENT THIS PHASE
THREE ASSISTANCE PLAN.
TO IMPLEMENT IT, EXECUTE IT AND
MAKE SURE IT GETS TO ALL THE
MEN AND WOMEN AND FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES AND SO FORTH.
THAT’S REALLY PRIORITY NUMBER
ONE.
WE MUST MAKE IT WORK.
I THINK WE HAVE GOTTEN OFF TO A
GOOD START.
IT IS UNPARALLELED ASSISTANCE.
THE SECOND POINT I’LL MAKE IS
THIS PANDEMIC AND THE
MITIGATION EFFECTS ESSENTIALLY
INTERRUPTED WHAT WAS A VERY
STRONG ECONOMIC BOOM FROM PRIOR
POLICIES AND, YOU KNOW, THE
PRIVATE SECTOR COMING ALIVE.
I SAY THAT BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THE ECONOMY IS FUNDAMENTALLY
SOUND.
IF WE CAN END OR CLOSE
GRADUALLY REMOVE THIS
INTERRUPTION, THEN I THINK
PEOPLE WILL COME BACK STRONG.
AND I THINK BUSINESS WILL COME
BACK STRONG.
>> Sandra: PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
HEAR THAT AND SAY IT ISN’T JUST
AN INTERRUPTION.
YOU LOOK AT THE COST OF THAT
STIMULUS PLAN WE’RE
IMPLEMENTING, THERE COULD BE
YEARS IF NOT A DECADE THAT IT
TAKES US TO RECOVER FROM THIS
AND WHY I’M ASKING YOU FOR SOME
SORT OF TIMELINE.
NOT JUST THE ECONOMIC.
>> I JUST DON’T AGREE, I’M
SORRY, SANDRA.
I DON’T THINK IT WILL TAKE
YEARS AND DECADES TO RECOVER
FROM THIS.
WE’VE HAD HEALTH WAVES,
PROBLEMS LIKE THIS BEFORE AND
COME BACK PRETTY RAPIDLY.
AGAIN, I THINK THAT’S AN
IMPORTANT POINT.
I MAY BE WRONG, BUT I WILL
MAINTAIN AS I THINK MOST PEOPLE
-- MOST ECONOMISTS BELIEVE THAT
THIS VIRUS, THE PANDEMIC AND
THE ACTIONS TO MITIGATE IT ARE
TEMPORARY.
AND THEREFORE THE DIFFICULTIES
AND THE INTERRUPTIONS I TALKED
ABOUT WILL PROVE TO BE
TEMPORARY.
OUR JOB RIGHT NOW IS TO HELP AS
MANY AMERICANS AS WE CAN WITH
THIS ASSISTANCE SO THEY CAN GET
THROUGH THIS.
THAT’S OUR JOB.
BUT I THINK AT SOME POINT IT
WILL BE OVER.
IT WILL WASH THROUGH.
THE VIRUS IS NOT GOING TO LAST
FOR YEARS.
I DON’T AGREE WITH THAT.
I FRANKLY DON’T KNOW EVERYBODY
AGREES THE VIRUS WILL LAST FOR
YEARS.
MAYBE WE’LL ALL BE WRONG.
OUR THINKING SINCE YOU ASKED IS
JUST TO DO THE BEST WE CAN TO
KEEP PEOPLE WORKING, TO KEEP
BUSINESSES ALIVE, AND THEREFORE
TO BE READY WHEN THE SHUT-IN
RECEDES AND WE GO BACK TO
OPENING UP BUSINESS IN THIS
COUNTRY AND USE OUR FREE
ENTERPRISE SYSTEM, THE BEST IN
THE WORLD.
I’M AFRAID I DISAGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK IT WILL BE TEMPORARY.
>> Sandra: TO BE CLEAR I WASN’T
SAYING THE VIRUS WILL LAST FOR
YEARS.
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT AND WHAT
THE RECOVERY LOOKS LIKE.
FINAL THOUGHT ON THE NEWS OF
THE DAY.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
ECONOMIC MODELS.
ARE WE LOOKING AT DOUBLE DIGIT
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THIS COUNTRY
NOW?
>> I THINK IN THE WEEKS AHEAD,
SANDRA.
IT WILL GET WORSE.
I CAN’T PULL ANY PUNCHES ON
THAT.
IT WILL GET WORSE.
THIS IS A VERY DEEP CONTRACTION.
THE NUMBERS ARE GOING TO COME
IN VERY BAD AND THEY’LL LOOK
TERRIBLE IN THE WEEKS AHEAD.
HOW MUCH LONGER, I DON’T REALLY
WANT TO FORECAST.
THAT’S UP TO THE HEALTH PEOPLE.
NO QUESTION IT WILL BE BAD.
ALSO NO QUESTION THAT WE’RE
PROVIDING MORE RELIEF AND
ASSISTANCE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
THAN EVER BEFORE IN OUR
NATION’S HISTORY.
AND IF WE HAVE TO DO MORE, WE
WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
THAT’S WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID.
WE’LL USE ALL THE POWER OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP
FOLKS WHO NEED THAT KIND OF
HELP.
>> Sandra: BASED ON WHAT YOU
SEE SO FAR, ARE THOSE CHECKS
GOING TO GET TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED THEM THE MOST IN A TIMELY
FASHION?
YOU DON’T HAVE TO LOOK FAR IN
REPORTS THIS MORNING ALL OVER
THE PLACE SOME PEOPLE WON’T GET
THEIR CHECKS UNTIL SEPTEMBER.
SO HOW FAST WILL PEOPLE GET
THOSE CHECKS, LARRY?
>> FIRST OF ALL THE
UNEMPLOYMENT CHECKS FROM THE
CURRENT LAW ARE GOING OUT RIGHT
NOW.
SECOND POINT ON UNEMPLOYMENT,
LABOR SECRETARY SCALIA HAS
GIVEN THE FUNDS TO THE STATES
AND UP TO THEM TO DISTRIBUTE.
WE HOPE THEY EXECUTE QUICKLY.
TAX REBATES CHECKS IN THE MAIL
DIRECTLY.
A COUPLE MORE WEEKS AS I SAID
THAT’S MORE OR LESS $175
MILLION PEOPLE, 1200 PER
PERSON, MIGHT BE 3,000 PER
FAMILY.
THE NEXT -- THE UNEMPLOYMENT
CHECKS ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED.
THE PLUS UP IN UNEMPLOYMENT
MIGHT TAKE ANOTHER WEEK OR TWO
FROM THE STATES BUT IT IS
COMING.
IN TERMS OF DIRECT CHECKS IN
THE MAIL TO HELP PEOPLE GET
THROUGH THIS THAT SHOULD COME
HOPEFULLY IN A COUPLE MORE
WEEKS.
I THINK IT WILL BE PRETTY
TIMELY.
>> Sandra: A CRUCIAL TIME FOR
THOSE PEOPLE.
LARRY KUDLOW, APPRECIATE YOUR